erst Anfang November und wir leben
bereits ein vorweihnachtliches Wunder in
der bundländerrunde hat Olaf Scholz der
alte hafenverkäufer zusammen mit den
Ministerpräsidenten diesmal ja
regelrecht Entscheidungen getroffen als
wäre das ihr Beruf und nun heißt es
morgen Kinder wird's Gas geben ja ja
haben sie ja auch so gefreut der
Gaspreis wird bei 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde gedeckelt der für Strom
bei 40 das ist eine wirklich sehr schöne
Entwicklung nachdem sich die Ampel
wochenlang eher mit sich selbst
beschäftigt hat offenbar nimmt man die
Sorgen und Nöte der Menschen doch ernst
hier der Kanzler am Dienstag beim
Bürgerdialog neulich kam jemand zu mir
und sagte Herr Scholz ich habe meinen
Elektroofen gerade auf ein Gasofen
umgestellt und habe ich wusste ich gar
nicht wie traurig ich gucken sollte
ja ja
so Olaf Scholz lacht nämlich doch
manchmal
nur halt meist an der falschen Stelle ja
also weiß nicht wie es Ihnen geht ich
finde diese Woche darf man die Regierung
ruhig auch mal loben zum Beispiel für
das 49 Euro Ticket das kommt nämlich
heißt für alle die auf dem Land leben in
ihrem Dorf wird auch in Zukunft kein Bus
halten
aber der Bus der dann nie hält ist dann
viel günstiger ist doch nicht schlecht
oder und das finde ich wichtiger der
doppelwurms wird zum ersten mal konkret
seit der bund-länderrunde fühlt sich die
ganze Nation endlich nicht mehr so
furchtbar ungewumst das ist doch schon
mal wichtig das ist doch schon mal toll
im Dezember übernimmt der Staat die
Abschlagszahlung für Gaskunden und im
März vielleicht sogar schon im Februar
wird man sehen greift dann die
gaspreisbremse warte mal was liegt noch
mal zwischen Dezember und März die
winterlücke bei der gaspreisbremse die
sogenannte winterlücke die sogenannte
winterlücke eine winterlücke könnte man
jetzt so eine Lücke föhnen wäre ein
gutes Signal wenn der Bund die
winterlücke schließen würde
nein
schade schade ja komm man sagt ja Mut
zur winterlücke ne und jetzt nörgeln wir
doch schon wieder rum wir meckern schon
wieder die Ampel hält sich an die
Vorschläge der Expertenkommission und
die sind gar nicht schlecht klar teuer
und sehr kompliziert aber so wird das
halt wenn man kaum Zeit hat für komplexe
Probleme ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel wie
wird die endgültige Höhe der Entlastung
für den Dezember vom Versorger errechnet
ganz einfach und ausdrücklich kein
Scherz warte mal ich rechne es mal für
sich vor das ist
ein Zwölftel der
jahresverbrauchsprognose JVP die der
Abschlagszahlung AZ im September 2022
zugrunde liegt wird multipliziert mit
dem Kilowattstundenpreis P im Dezember
22 dazu addieren wir ein Zwölftel des
Jahres brutto-grundpreises JBG stand
September fertig
ja mehr ist es nicht
mehr ist es nicht es ist Pippi einfach
meine Damen und Herren ja easy peasy
also außer sie sind Besitzer eines
größeren Hauses mit mehreren
Mietparteien dann müssen Sie die Formel
gerade natürlich noch anteilig
runterrechnen auf jede einzelne Wohnung
wie kommt das so an bei den Vermietern
[Musik]
ganz gut glaube ich oder ja die freuen
sich die Vermieter wie gesagt jetzt
müssen wir es leider so kompliziert
machen weil der Sommer komplett verpennt
wurde im März hätte die Ampel mit der
Arbeit an ihren Deckeln anfangen können
dann hätten wir die jetzt schon und
warum schaffen die Österreicher direkt
Überweisungen ihre Bürger aber wir nicht
warum
Sissi und Franz haben schon im September
500 Euro gekriegt und Himmels wählen
alte Regel was der ölsichthaft schafft
jeder
dabei steht das mit den Direktzahlungen
seit knapp einem Jahr im
ampelkoalitionsvertrag es steht da drin
hier kindgerechter pro Tipp für die
nächsten Krisenlagen
[Musik]
pass auf es ist ganz einfach
wenn man anfängt ist man eher fertig
noch mal früher anfangen eher fertig
jetzt kapiert
[Musik]
siehst du kinderleicht
ja hätte man machen sollen einfach
früher anfangen beim nächsten Mal denn
die Inflation macht ja auch keine Pause
alles wird immer teurer ich behaupte in
diesem Jahr ist Brokkoli plötzlich sowas
wie das perfekte Weihnachtsgeschenk wenn
es wenn es so weitergeht wobei die Krise
natürlich sehr unterschiedlich
wahrgenommen wird ist ja klar für
Menschen mit niedrigem Einkommen ist die
Inflation viel schlimmer weil sie einen
höheren Anteil dieses Einkommens für
Energie und Lebensmittel ausgeben andere
sind deutlich entspannter Glamour
Shoppingmeile in Nordrhein-Westfalen
worauf wird hier verzichtet haben sie
mich jetzt aber auf dem falschen Fuß
erwischt wir sollen ja alle Energie
sparen ja das haben sie mitgekriegt
ich habe sehr vieles auf kalt gestellt
also Händewaschen in im Gästebad und so
weiter ist dann nicht mehr warm
ja auch die Wohlhabenden bringen Opfer
also die Gäste der wohl haben dann aber
trotzdem ja wir alle müssen in diesen
Tagen den Gucci Gürtel enger schnallen
vielleicht mal abgesehen von den
krisengewinnern denn die gibt es ja auch
über einige wird in Deutschland ständig
geredet Ölkonzerne Stromerzeuger über
andere meiner Meinung nach viel zu wenig
sprechen wir heute zum Beispiel endlich
mal über unsere Banken meine Damen und
Herren ja die haben aktuell zwar Angst
vor Kreditausfällen leben aber natürlich
auch von Schulden beziehungsweise Zinsen
und so gesehen läuft es echt Gold laut
der Internetplattform smava haben zum
Jahresanfang rund 6,6 Millionen Deutsche
ihre Konten überzogen das sollen 17%
mehr gewesen sein als vor der
Jahresfrist wegen der höheren
Nebenkostenabrechnung könnte die Zahl
überzogene Konten noch weiter zulegen
und potsplits genauso ist es gekommen
liebe Zuschauer immer mehr Deutsche
überziehen Ihr Konto für Nebenkosten und
Lebensmittel der Dispozins in
Deutschland liegt aktuell schon bei über
10 Prozent damit sind wir europäischer
Spitzenreiter zusammen mit den Griechen
ja dabei ist der Dispo der asozialste
Zins überhaupt es gibt gar keinen
asozialeren sollte man wirklich nur im
Notfall und auch nur für kurze Zeit
nutzen während die Banken an jedem
zusätzlichen Dispo Prozentpunkt
340 Millionen Euro mehr pro Jahr
verdienen oder noch anschaulicher
erklärt wenn das hier die
Refinanzierungskosten der Bank sind fünf
Zentimeter dann liegt der Dispokredit
ich will das mal sagen bei naja es
braucht immer einen kleinen Moment bei
zwei Metern
ah 2 Meter Zinsen jetzt habe ich es
verstanden vielen Dank ja manche Sachen
kannst du nur im Zollstock erklären der
hohe Dispozins schon vor der Zinswende
eine absolute Unverschämtheit und jetzt
haben etliche Banken bei uns noch mal
erhöht meine an der Krise verdienen das
ist doch das hinterletzte ich habe da
neulich auch mit meinem Banker drüber
gesprochen
schockhaus das ist ja wohl das
hinterletzte jetzt auch noch den Dispo
erhöhen der Dispo ist nachweislich der
Einstieg in die Schuldenfalle
Schuldenfalle bei ihnen klingt das so
negativ wir nennen das langfristige
Kundenbindung unser Problem sind die
Leute die keine Schulden machen schon
jesus hat zu seinen Jüngern gesagt gehe
raus und verschuldet euch für
irgendwelchen sinnlosen scheiß dafür
wurde Weihnachten schließlich erfunden
und nicht für Leute wie ihn hier
disperkredit wird nicht überzogen wir
haben genug Geld auf dem Konto
nö da ist er stolz auf sein Konto oder
möchte gerne Nikolaus ich sag ihm mal
auf wen ich stolz bin auf alle Kollegen
die gerade gegen den verdammten
Zeitgeist aber mal richtig drauf packen
beim Dispo hier die Hall of gear der
deutschen Kreditinstitute ganz vorne die
VR Bank Landsberg Ammersee mit
14,29 Prozent leck mich fett was für
badass motherfucker wenn da noch einer
so blöd bzw so nett ist den Dispo zu
überziehen dann landest du dabei bis zu
20 Prozent oh sorry ich muss ganz kurz
warten bis meine Erektion wieder
abklingt
Entschuldigung könnten die Banken in
dieser wirklich historischen Krise nicht
ausnahmsweise mal Partner ihrer Kunden
sein gerade jetzt wo hohe Inflation und
horrende Energiekosten viele Haushalte
an die Grenze finanzieller Belastbarkeit
bringen seien die Finanzinstitute aber
auch moralisch gefordert so Fachleute
[Gelächter]
Finanzinstitute und Moral im selben Satz
das ist mein Humor meiner nicht was wir
brauchen in Deutschland ist ein
zinsdeckel deutsche Banken sind nicht
mal verpflichtet eine dispozinserhöhung
mitzuteilen ich musste als Kunde auch
gar nicht zustimmen nee da haben wir
kurz darüber nachgedacht aber dann ist
uns eingefallen dass viele
wahrscheinlich nicht zustimmen würden
warum also fragen ja im übrigen Herr
welke wir tragen ja auch ein immenses
Risiko ich meine wir reden hier von
ungesicherten Krediten hallo die
Ausfallquote beim Dispo liegt bei unter
einem Prozent jeder Ausfall einer zu
viel deswegen setze ich bei meinen
Kreditkunden auch immer auf direkte
Ansprache ach hier wie aufs Stichwort
unser Herr Hartwig sehr netter Kunde
Azubi hat jetzt sogar seinen
Überziehungskredit ausgereizt Herr
Hartwig sie kennen ja den Ablauf diesen
Vertrag steht 20 Prozent und jede Woche
einen Finger
Holger Stock aus meine Damen und Herren
[Musik]
meine ganz andere Frage was macht
eigentlich unsere Opposition CDU und CSU
suchen seit einem Jahr ihre Rolle also
ein neues inhaltliches Profil und ich
sag mal die Suche war stand heute nicht
so erfolgreich ja ja ist ja auch
schwierig es ist ja auch schwierig was
ist konservativ was wollen die Leute von
einer modernen konservativen Partei
Friedrich Merz hat neulich mal
spaßeshalber den Testballon ukrainischer
sozialtourismus gestartet kam nicht
richtig gut an man blinkt mal rechts man
blinkt mal links aber was ist der
Markenkern wissen sie selber nicht was
man auch an der Schwammigkeit des
neuesten csu-motors erkennt schon
gesehen Hightech und Heimat Kracher oder
ja
beides gute Sachen da hat keiner was
dagegen sonst noch Vorschläge
Leberkäse und Laser Gigabit und Gamsbart
WLAN und Weißbier BMW und bierschiss und
da geht so viel
da geht so viel ja beim CSU-Parteitag in
Augsburg letztes Wochenende hat Markus
Söder einmal mehr gegen das Bürgergeld
gehetzt die Union droht sogar ist im
Bundesrat zu blockieren und das jetzt wo
viele Hartz IV Familien zum Monatsende
nicht mehr wissen wovon sie das Essen
für ihre Kinder bezahlen sollen es wird
ja ein Top Zeitpunkt und
transfer-empfänger gegen Niedriglöhner
auszuspielen jedenfalls wenn man durch
einen seltenen Geburtsfehler ohne
Skrupel geboren wurde Kassiererin
Busfahrer Polizist
Friseurin beispielsweise die in Berlin
oder München sind werden am Ende wenn
sie arbeiten weniger haben als wenn sie
nicht arbeiten ja das ist lassen es mich
arbeitsrechtlich korrekt formulieren
herbeikonstruierte Scheiße meine Damen
und Herren ja jemand der Mindestlohn in
Vollzeit arbeitet hat in aller Regel am
Monatsende natürlich mehr als ein
bürgergeld-empfänger Söder kämpft für
Geringverdiener dabei hat seine Union
sich über Jahre mit zäh Clown gegen den
Mindestlohn gewährt dass wir immer noch
einen der größten Niedriglohnsektoren
Europas haben das ist doch die
eigentliche Schande und Söder macht ein
Fass auf Wegen 50 Euro mehr Bürgergeld
da fällt mir ein ist die CSU eigentlich
noch eine christliche Partei oder ist
Gott schon ausgetreten ja
ich könnte es verstehen muss ich sagen
und was die Union auch schlimm findet
Hartz IV Familien dürfen demnächst
150.000 Euro schon Vermögen behalten ja
ja kennt man ja hat ja jeder von uns in
der Nachbarschaft diese steinreichen
Hartz IV-Familien in der Realität
statistisch absolut zu vernachlässigen
aber wenn man will extrem gruselig
wissen Sie eigentlich was da ab Januar
auf uns zukommt
Deutschland legendäre Industrienation
Heimat Bienen fleißiger Niedriglöhner
ohne große Ansprüche doch diese
Erfolgsgeschichte endet am 1 Januar denn
dann kommt Boss
Sekunden später stürmen deutsche in
Massen die Jobcenter um sich ihre fette
Stütze abzuholen nur ein zwei Trottel
arbeiten noch weiter und wissen selber
nicht warum
Chirurgen lassen mitten in der Herz-OP
das skalpellfallen
der komplette FC Bayern steht nur noch
um bei laufen sich einfach nicht mehr
lohnt und gierige Harzer behalten bis zu
150.000 Euro Schonvermögen Robert das
Bürgergeld ist da wir müssen nie wieder
arbeiten
das Bürgergeld ein Land
das Bürgergeld
die große Bedrohung im nächsten Jahr
meine Fresse
Kruzifixe in Schulen aufhängen aber
Stimmung gegen das Bürgergeld machen
meine allein die Vorstellung dass dieser
Mann um ein Haar unser Bundeskanzler
geworden wäre junge da sind wir alle
Armin Laschet zu ewiger Dankbarkeit
verpflichtet ja deswegen haben wir ja im
Studio seit Monaten das Denkmal des
Unbekannten Söder verhinderers ja diese
Sendung hat sich immer für Armin Laschet
eingesetzt immer
ich dreckige Heuchler so
wir fassen kurz zusammen die CSU auf
Sinnsuche kämpft gegen Bürgergeld schon
Vermögen und ganz wichtig gegen die
verdammte vognis vocness wo kommt die
nochmal her die vogelness aus Berlin
heraus vocness
dies ist und es sage ich euch in aller
Deutlichkeit keine neue Freiheit sondern
illiberales zwanghaftes Spießertum ja
CSU-Politiker gegen Spießertum finde den
Fehler
drei Sekunden später war in der Rede
natürlich wieder sehr anders beim
winnetou-verbot das ist nie gab wie wir
alle wissen auf der anderen Seite und
das gehört auch zur Wirkung Wahrheit
haben gerade wieder deutsche Kitas Mails
an ihre Eltern geschickt Mails die
anlässlich von Halloween und genau eine
Woche vor dem 11.11 für Sensibilität bei
der kostümwahlwärmt ist schon wichtiges
Thema denn die Verunsicherung ist
inzwischen tatsächlich groß
katjana Gertz leitet in dieser Kita die
iltis-gruppe heute soll ein Workshop die
Eltern für Karneval sensibilisieren und
bitte Leute keine Rollen oder
Geschlechter Klischees Krankenschwester
ein absolutes No-Go
Alleinerziehende geschiedene Chefärztin
jederzeit
kleiner Landwirt süß denkt man aber
Vorsicht da müsst ihr eure Kinder schon
fragen bist du ein Biobauer oder
wir sitzen eines mastbetriebs mit 5.000
Tieren dann geht das Kostüm gar nicht
geh auf dein Zimmer Mama hat dich nicht
mehr lieb aber hey natürlich sollen die
Kinder trotzdem Spaß am Verkleiden haben
ist doch klar hier unser neuer Erzieher
der Justin führt uns jetzt mal ein paar
problematische Kostüme vor müssen wir
gar nicht drüber reden absolute
Katastrophe da kann ich mich für den
Justin echt nur entschuldigen du hast
doch gesagt ich soll die Scheiße
anziehen jeder macht mal Fehler komm
nächstes Kostüm google mal Kolonialismus
bitte nicht also es sei denn er ist aus
Katar und hat gerade eine WM gekauft
also wie gesagt Scheich geht gar nicht
steht aber für Selbstjustiz und Macho
Thum mein Gott
ja niedliche Katze
leider überhaupt nicht niedlich die
Viecher töten jedes Jahr unzählige
Singvögel Mörder
aber das wichtigste vorsicht vor
kultureller Aneignung Geisha Bob Marley
Mexikaner nein nein nein
überhaupt noch übrig ja gute Frage ja
zum Beispiel keine kulturelle Aneignung
vor der fällt mir gerade ein der war ja
Österreicher Mist geht auch nicht gut
also schön Fasching euch und den Kids
hello
[Musik]
katjana Gertz
über
Verwirrung zum Thema Kostüme so meine
Damen und Herren aber ein anderes
wichtiges Anliegen des csu-parteitags
haben wir ja noch gar nicht erwähnt man
ist konsequent gegen die von Karl
Lauterbach geplante Cannabis
Legalisierung ja dazu muss man wissen
die CSU war immer schon gegen Drogen die
man nicht trinken kann
und Gras legal gesehen also das Öffnen
und wirklich die Büchse der bekifften
Pandora ich möchte nicht dass meine
Tochter in einer Gesellschaft aufwächst
wurde sich Crack und Kokain kaufen kann
wie Zahnpasta und Kaugummi so so wird es
kommen meine Damen und Herren ja bald
sitzt walter White beim DM an der Kasse
und ihre Tochter kriegt zu jedem Crack
natürlich
ja cannabis ist für die Gehirne junger
Menschen gar nicht mal so gut aber sie
besorgen es sich jetzt ja auch schon nur
eben auf dem Schwarzmarkt wo der Dealer
in der Tat auch noch harte Drogen im
Angebot hat Zahnpasta weiß ich jetzt gar
nicht so genau ja
hallo Leute Ich bin's der heute-show
Mime Ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
Scheiß und liegt
memes wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
Kanal
was zur Hölle ist ein meme Ersteller
[Musik]